five
four three two one should be live
chairman
thank you good evening and welcome to
this over euro scrutiny committee
meeting
as the crime and disorder committee
meeting on thursday the 22nd of october
2020
my name is councillor michael helm and i
am chairman of this committee
this meeting is held under new
regulations which came into effect on
the fourth of april
in response to the coveted situation
and there are just a few housekeeping
issues to run through
first of all please class everyone
present in this meeting
to ensure your microphones remain muted
and your video feed is off
when not addressing the committee this
will reduce
background noise and avoid any
unintentional disturbance
[Music]
this meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live
and recorded and by being present in
this meeting you are giving your
consent to being recorded members of
officers
members
members members
members and officers during each item
please use the chat function
of the meeting to indicate if you wish
to speak i will
invite you at the appropriate time
members are reminded that apart from
indicating you wish to speak or that you
have to leave
the meeting the chat function should not
be used for
questions or any other purpose please do
not use
the raised hands function as this is not
available on all members devices
when speaking and referring to a gender
paper please ensure
you reference the page and paragraph
number
and last if members need to leave the
chat leave the meeting
at any point please do make this known
and use the chat function
to signify that you need to leave the
meeting
now my ask officers and other parties
taking part in the meeting to introduce
themselves
starting mr holmes mr holmes
good evening members richard holmes
director of service delivery
okay mr clark
good evening members uh spencer clark
i'm the community safety
partnership manager at modern district
council thank you
chief inspector scott haynes
good evening members chief inspector
steve scott haynes district commander
for
chelsea malden thank you very much
miss bird
good evening members tara bird community
services officer for the meeting thank
you chairman
is there any officers present
good evening members paul dodson
director of strategy performance and
governance
thank you paul is there anybody else
no okay tara please can you now carry
out the roll call
of members to confirm who's in
attendance in attendance thank you
thank you chairman members to call your
names up um alphabetically if you could
just confirm
if you're in attendance please starting
with councillor bell
yes president good evening sarah good
evening members
council miss fleming president tara
thank you very much councillor helm
you're here yeah
councillor heard um good evening
chairman good evening tara and
colleagues present thank you casa morley
good evening everyone present thank you
very much catherine nunn
yes good evening tara good evening
members and everybody
i'm president good evening thank you
council fiddle
i've got to say it this way evening all
uh i am present
very much and chairman could i ask if
there's any other members in attendance
if they could just advise please
sorry all right
[Music]
thank you thank you cancer councillor
bamford i mean
present
morris did you want to say something
councilor morris is in attendance and
hello
hello hello thank you thank you
anybody else i'm also here tara
chancello
thank you chairman thank you very much
hello thank you item 3
is recommended the minutes of the
meeting held on the 14th of november
2019
found on pages 7 to 14 are approved as a
true
accurate record sorry to interrupt
apologies for absence
oh sorry yeah apologies for absence i
missed that one out yeah
apologies for absence uh chairman
apologies i've been received from
councillor
dueck okay uh move on to the
the minutes i've got the pharah's
accurate record
um i'll run through the pages page seven
page eight page nine
page ten page eleven
sorry chairman uh a couple of things um
on can i just start on page five please
yes question um it's uh
minute number nine six four yes
it said that council had requested it be
clarified whether the 185 stock checks
conducted related to the malden or
chelmsford area
okay i will be speaking about that later
on but the
after after that it says police
accessibility
um it's the middle line of that it said
members were advised that the government
had changes
that should be changed i believe okay
can you
amend that dara
yes of course channel we can do that
page six
page seven
page eight page
nine page nine please chairman yes
uh let me see one two three four
five paragraphs down the one that starts
inspector barry boov
uh three lines up from the bottom uh it
talks about
a discrete rural team i think that
should be discretionary rural team
or if it's discrete it should be spelled
a different way
okay can you amend it please tara
oh yes of course chairman thank you page
10
page 11
iso move you're great agreed okay
if any members wishes to raise uh
matters of accuracy you've done that
okay you've all agreed it
agreed nobody wants to speak
i would there was a couple of points
that i would like to raise in relation
to the minutes but they're not
corrections
okay carry on thank you um it really
[Music]
it really relates to uh my
disappointment this is on
page uh page top of page
nine that the police and crime
commissioner
uh had uh failed to attend
the last meeting which was held in
october
and obviously there wasn't a march
meeting
and i am once again disappointed that
the police and crime commissioner is not
here
uh in order uh that some of the crime
figures which i'll be
uh referring to later on um uh
i i was rather hoping that he would be
here to
to justify some of those some of those
figures
the other question that i had asked
was whether or not the 185 stock checks
related to the malden or the chelmsford
area
they might be able to help me please can
anyone help with that please
i'm happy to take it at a later date
with those figures
so sorry can i just um get in that those
figures would relate
to both chelmsford and malden
because my understanding is we are
unable to separate
them at this time okay
thank you very much thank you right okay
that's that's done that's all tied it up
with public health participation there's
none
the declarations of interest to close
the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests
or other community interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
either
the business on the agenda having regard
to the paragraph
six to eight inclusive the code of
conduct for members
members are reminded that they should
also require to disclose any such
interests
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise throughout the meeting
if any member has a interest to clear
please use the chat
function now to indicate and i will
invite them to speak
anybody kevin that wasn't
indicated chairman do i have to i'm in
attendance do i need to when i'm in
attendance i can't remember now i should
do shanab i will do
if you if you want i'm just also an
essex county councillor
yeah okay of course the police and crime
commissioner
um close liaison with essex county not
available
chief inspector scott haynes please
yes sorry chairman my buttons i wasn't
quick enough with
i do apologize
good evening everyone um so as you'll
see in the um
information that you've been sent out um
currently
with the the basic figures of
performance
um we've got a 15.7
increase in antisocial behavior although
happily a two percent reduction in all
crime
um antisocial behavior is being fueled
um
by some of the coveted issues that have
been highlighted certainly we're getting
a lot of information around
fly tipping and um
around speeding motorists that's all
recorded under that same
banner and we're obviously addressing
those
violence against person gains in
significant increase
of 12
but again we know that some of that is
coming from
our increase in recording some of the
violence that is and stalking issues
that are happening around
domestic violence domestic violence as a
whole as we know
due to covid we have seen some worrying
increases
across the county some of those were
initially
hidden i would suggest because people
were
not contacting the police but going to
other agencies and to charities
um we are seeing that turning the corner
now and those charities are
directing people to the police and so
we're in a better position to
deal with those matters and to
put in positive steps to help vulnerable
victims around that
i'm going to come away from the figures
and give you a
wider update on policing
so we continue with our operation aegis
which is our um policing
of organized crime groups we had a
significant success last year
which removed a quite serious organized
crime group
we have seen a number of people try to
step
forward to take over that slot but with
our town team officers working in
conjunction with the serious crime
uh teams we've had some significant
successes with
a warrant which recovered fifty thousand
pounds worth of class a drugs
and a significant stop check
by the town team officers which
recovered over 20 000 pounds worth of
drugs and cash
and subsequently arrested two people for
that
those patrols continue um operation
enlightenment which my colleague um
barry spoke to you about last time and
this is our engagement with schools
um as you can imagine with the kovi
lockdown that's been somewhat stretched
and more difficult
as the skills have come back we've
ensured that
the community policing team officers
have gone back into
schools to assist one with coveted
legislation and two
with dealing with any matters that have
been highlighted
during the time children have been away
we put some particular emphasis
on giving children the opportunity to
talk to us and to the pastoral care
teams
to look around any issues they may have
had at home that they have been unable
to
talk to people about we have also
increased our child and young persons
officers
to four from three so we're looking at
widening our net with schools currently
we do a lot of work with the
senior schools but we are looking to
move that to junior schools as well
go to engagement um our pcsos and town
team offices are our main
level of engagement where we used to do
all of our coffee with cops etc
um those things have not been going
ahead as much as we would have wanted
due to coving restrictions but we have
started to increase those now
and doing them in a covered safer way as
we can
we're using teams although as you can
see i'm not great with the buttons on it
where we can to develop those
opportunities to talk to various groups
and of course situations like this allow
us to do that
if i go to our special constabulary
we're now in a position where we have
three community special constables who
are dedicated to the malden area
um they are now in post and in place um
same as all other special constables
fully trained
but in this instance they work um
specifically in malden and would only be
taken away from malden if there was a
major incident
we have a fourth community special
constable who's working at southwood and
ferris
we continue to try and build those
numbers
um our neighbourhood watch system
um here in the malden area
still looking to grow that we're still
looking to put in place
the whatsapp group um that we have
in chelmsford at this side um and
due to the lead of the neighborhood
watch from this area
stepping down there is a a gap there
that needs to be filled chelmsford
neighborhood watch have kindly taken on
some of the responsibilities
around treasury the treasury of it etc
and so they are assisting us to try and
find a new leader
of the neighbourhood watch to increase
what's going on there
um community policing team this is the
big one
our community policing team we know work
from
the community safety partnership um
civic building
in chelmsford um i would really like
to move that back into the molded area
currently
we don't have physical space to do that
we're um currently looking at
negotiations through mr holmes to
find some more space at the city council
so that we can bring an element
of the community policing team back to
the area
um that's still in the early stages at
the moment but that's what we are
aiming to progress
rural engagement we've got some
really good links now with our rural
engagement team
we've seen increased patrols by them
lots of licensing visits
and a number of operations around fly
tipping
and joint operations around metal theft
that's been reasonably successful
but not all um
as a disruption tool it's worked quite
well whether we've found the people who
are actually doing
the main offenses i'm not sure that we
have at this time
um stop search which i know um counselor
heard is particularly interested in
unfortunately i do not have the figures
this time round
because the system has gone down on us
and um
dawn wallace has been trying everything
all day to get me figures but i don't
have them
i will report those back to yourself
chair
when i have those thank you
um and that's my update are there any
questions
tara has anyone indicated to ask
questions please
oh yes chairman i have a few um i don't
know if you want members of the
committee first would be councillor
heard then councillor bell
and an admission councillor channel and
councillor morning
sorry councilman is a member of the
committee as well have also asked to
speak
first okay so uh councillor heard i
believe he's the first one chairman
thank you thank you chairman and uh
thank you uh chief inspector scott
haynes uh for that update
um let me say that i'm very supportive
of the police and the good work that
they do in malden
um and i think that it is the aim of
this committee
to try and make sure that they have the
best
um facilities available at the moment
you spoke about um adequate
or you spoke about the space within the
council offices now i know that a year
ago
we were talking about having an addition
uh
of an interview room can you tell me
is that in place yet please right so
that's not in place at this stage
um there were a number of issues around
um
location of the the room um
two weeks ago it may be two and a half
weeks ago uh mr hose and myself had a
meeting to go over where we were around
that
during that meeting we were able to
identify
another area within the council building
which would be much more suitable
to bring the community team into and
increase our footprint so that the
interview room could actually stay
within our current footprint
does that make sense um
i'm just awaiting the final figures on
that once i have those i'll be going to
my command with the um
with with the begging bowl in hand for
the money to make sure that it happens
okay thank you very much indeed uh and
can you confirm that there will be
adequate facilities for those
offices who are there and i'm talking
particularly about
locker spaces because i know there is a
shortage of those can you
confirm that those will be in place
right those will be in place if
so the new area that we have looked at
if that area does come off in the way
that we would like it to
we will actually see an increase in
locker space
which will allow us to incorporate
bringing the community an element of the
community policing team in as well
thank you very much i'm sorry to hold
this i've got a couple more questions
chairman is that if i may
oh thank you very much um
the the next thing and this is really
why i wanted to speak to the police and
crime commissioner is because he did
promise us
uh some directional signs to actually
tell the public where the police station
was
so there was a sign from the old police
station
with a directional sign pointing down
fanbridge road
one at warwick drive and the other one
in wants road
and another one at the council offices
to at least telling people where the
police station is
can you tell me what the progress is on
that please
right um i haven't had an update from
the
um pfcc's office so i don't know where
they stand with it
i know that when i did a check
of the old police station looking at
putting some signage there myself
um i discovered that that had already
been sold so it was no longer part of
our estate
so i couldn't put anything on that
building um as to where
the directional signs from the pfcc's
office
i'm afraid i don't have an update on
that but i'll certainly um
see what i can find out for you thank
you very much
and uh just uh on the
facilities again i think we
we know that there used to be an
emergency telephone outside malden
police station
and i was informed that we were going to
play
to place this emergency telephone
outside the current police station
and indeed if possible at one in burnham
uh
but uh certainly in malden can you tell
me what the progress is on that please
okay so the telephone has been agreed
um i chased that last week
and i'm literally waiting for the
facility guys to come out
and place it everything's ready to go
we've identified the location
that has been agreed with um council
officers um i'm literally just waiting
for a workman to turn up with a big
yellow phone
okay that's fine um chairman i've got
some questions on the figures but i'm
happy to give way to other members if
they'd like to speak at
first if you wouldn't mind know who's
next
uh casa morley is next
yes thank you chairman um sorry get the
camera on
um yes um thank you chief inspector
for coming in and giving us that um
update
um i know what it's me but i have
actually noticed a decrease in the fly
tipping
going around and and i do get people ask
me
what do they do if they um see it do
they call the police do they call the
environment agency
uh just read a bit of direction of what
i can give them
and um yes and i do hope that we can
sort something out for you in boulder
because i think that's really important
as well thank you yep um
who was next sorry carry on sorry
fly tipping uh reporting of um
if it is um found after the event
so to speak so we've actually just got
some items there
that should go in through the council
and environment agency
if we have someone physically there fly
tipping i would suggest that that's an
emergency
call to 999. okay all right
no problem pass it on thank you very
much
anybody else uh councillor bells next
chairman
thanks to bill please thank you chairman
um good evening inspector
i'm just curious about the uh impact of
the lockdown on county lines activity
have you seen a significant
fool or criminals using different routes
how's
how's that worked so initially we saw a
significant um
fall uh like everyone uh
they had to change their method of
working
it has gone back up to the levels we
were seeing
pre-covered most definitely and we're
seeing people coming in
certainly using the train lines um
i've had to get in contact with
my colleagues at the british transport
police
where we have seen um in particular from
the stratford area
a number of people coming up to
chelmsford initially and then moving out
from there
um we're still not seeing the cuckooing
that we hear about in the rest of the
county to such a high level
because of our transport links that we
don't get that as much
and realistically on the molden side
it's actually more homegrown
um dealing than county line dealing if
i'm perfectly honest
um certainly what we're seeing a lot
more of
is the use of cocaine
as the main item to be sold rather than
crack which is what we would normally
associate with okay county lines but
candy lines unfortunately
are still there and we're still
combating them
as best we can thank you that's great
thanks very much
right um margo back to tipping again you
had a large scale operation at
bradwell i believe major tipping going
on there that's now moved to lower
burnham road at marsh farm are you aware
of that
we are okay i'm working with the
environment agency
and other partners right okay let's said
the better then
councillor channel i believe next isn't
it uh
i think with people right okay i'm sorry
thank you
council okay thank you uh just switching
on
uh one of the objectives
is um about increasing confidence in
dealing with rural crime
and one of the things i still really
don't feel
yet living in one of the rural villages
yeah we
apart from speed checks we don't see any
police officers
one of the things that we talked about
last year was hair coursing
it is still going on extensively in the
great tottenham ward
we've had major problems again with it
this year
and it's upsetting for residents it's
it's upsetting
that we have the dogs loose afterwards
and and that we have to deal
deal with that mess so that that again
really is something that that needs to
to be addressed um
it's important that one of the things
that you yeah
it's really good that you send out the
photographs about what what's happening
in the molden
and it is when i look at the photographs
that get sent by the elc
it is molden and burnham that tend to be
in those photographs i it's very rare
for me to publicize or be able to
publish something about
a a village i was able uh recently
because of the community speed watching
in yeah the the police officers doing a
speed check
in great autumn so yeah i know the
resources are difficult
and yeah and most crime happens probably
in the towns and things like that
but where we've got the increase in yeah
again i've
i get things about vehicles being
damaged and
there was something recently on a
facebook page about someone approaching
a a vehicle in great autumn
and so those are the things that i i
would like more focus on
if we had the resources and and yeah to
deal with
um if we can get the community team
into mold and i think that would be
brilliant and yeah i think it's
something that the council should focus
on doing
and it's good that you've had that
meeting with richard
yes it's um yeah hair coursing
is one of those really difficult
situations
um my colleagues in the rural engagement
team
have done a great deal of work on hair
coursing
and um they they
really do react quickly when they get
the calls around that
um visibility um
getting the community team out to
malden so that we're closer we cut
20 30 minutes off of the travel times
that is the right thing to do and that's
what i really want to get um the
officers doing out there
the longer term aim for me is
to look at a full
community rural community team
but i need the resourcing to do that um
currently on my community team
i've got six vacancies um as quickly as
i recruit people
people move on retire etc so
the pfc seizing increase has really
increased the level of numbers i've got
i've just got a recruit into them all
the way i know when i did this
very meeting a couple of what two or
three ago
i was happily saying i've got the whole
team it was fantastic
since then there's been more movement
and it's it's an ever moving
um beast so at the moment
i've got a few gaps and i'm hoping we
can fill them as quickly as we can
thank you um any more members
um yes chairman accounts mrs chandler
and councillor morris and then
councillor herb wants to come back
and council fleming as well and
councillor none
counselor channel then first please
uh thank you very much chairman for
allowing me to speak
sorry sorry to keep you waiting no no no
problem sorry i couldn't get to you
before but i did send any um
texty thing to tara thank you chairman
very much
um and counselor bell and i sometimes do
think along the same lines cosplay
southeast she uh very words out my mouth
and it is
county lines actually um and the drug um
trafficking in the area and i was
looking at the figures
and the tables below especially to
malden um but what i did notice
generally it appears that drug offenses
um were down that's on your top table
then
trafficking of drugs was up and
possession was down but in malden
it appears to be the pattern is that the
trafficking
is down and the drug offense is up um
and um also the uh possession of drugs
up
and in fact trafficking of drugs was
down by 64 percent
i know small figures but i was quite
alarmed by that and i don't know if
you're aware of a report that went
actually to essex county council
recently
which is a report of a task and finished
of the
um which was looking at drugs you know
gangs county lines knife crime
and they actually did advising that
there's 40 map gangs in essex and many
of them home grown so i was sort of
when you said most of them in mauldin
are homegrown i'm quite interested to
know do we know the statistics of that
and i think what concerns me having
worked with children and young families
in the past
and you know especially our school
children those school children that
might be down
in our schools um you know we've got the
secondary schools and everything and hey
bridge
and of course there is normally a
criminal exploitation of young people
about this
and so that's an air of concern for me
and in my division
um i hear things and also in my
ward of mainland which i represent and
i'm just wondering
you know i always tell people if they're
aware of anything to contact obviously
the police
and i think that's the first form so
really it's just about those figures
because
trafficking down in drugs of malden by
64 percent
and then hearing there's 40 ma gangs in
essex and they're homegrown and you
mentioned homegrown
um i wondered could you just perhaps
elucidate a bit on those figures because
you know it's a real big issue i think
in our district well it is in essex and
suffolk but i i'm obviously concerned
about malden district um hence why the
open scrutiny committee tonight is
looking into these things of course
right
so trafficking of drugs is
that larger figures
of um drugs coming into the
area so if we had if we take the county
lines example
if we had three county lines
coming into malden every single day
we made arrests on those lines um
where we caught people with substantial
amounts
of drugs then it would be classed as
trafficking
moving it in what we have found
is that particularly since the um work
from
the um these serious crime
team took out what we knew to be the
largest trafficker
within malden we're seeing a much
lower level of dealer in the area
so the arrests are for possession
with intent to supply they're not at the
same levels
we have no doubt the same level of drugs
are coming in what we haven't
identified at this time are the main
trafficker of those drugs and that's
what we need to identify and that's why
you'll see those figures
reduce because we aren't yet
at the point where we're taking those
people out so our possession
has increased which shows that the
officers are out there they're doing
legitimate stock checks they're picking
up
on the local level dealers
or small dealers coming into
the malden district and arresting those
and charging those with offences
thank you very much thank you chief
inspector and thank you
chairman for letting me participate
thank you
next one tara
thank you did you want to go back to
committee members or do you want me just
doing the order chairman they came in
uh about the committee members okay so
the next one would be counselor heard's
asked to come back on figures
um thank you very much um chairman um
i i know chief inspector that the uh the
the force
anti-social behavior has increased by
12 and violence against the person
4.2 and sexual offences are down
um but in malden um
asp has gone up by 15
you've already spoken about that uh
violence against the person up 186
and that's gone up by 12.5 percent
and sexual defense has increased by 35
which is 37.6 percent um
other offenses like theft criminal
damage
uh etcetera have been reduced um
i hope that we're not going for the low
hanging fruit
because uh we've already spoken about
your priorities which is reducing
anti-social behavior
protecting the vulnerable people and
reducing crime overall
so my question is in relation to
uh the well first of all on the on those
figures how do you feel about those
figures
and the second thing is i know that um
essex is broken up into three
policing areas north south and west
and each of those areas have a
team like a squad if you like
that look after
county lines i think they're called
raptor teams
that's right yeah right okay so um
i know that the north is a massive area
uh to police and i understand that
but i don't necessarily need the figures
tonight
but i would be interested to know how
uh the north section
compares to south and west
um because i think that uh looking at
the figures
for trafficking in chelmsford i think it
says um
62 offenses
no sorry that's braintree 94 offense is
89
in 2019 so i'm just a bit concerned
about
how they compare and are they getting
uh the correct number of resources
for that please okay so opera operation
raptor
has just gone through a significant
change um
the raptor teams were all owned by the
individual um local policing areas
so north south and west they now come
under one
um command our operational policing
command
based at borum and um chief inspector
lewis basford
runs that team with superintendent
sorry detective superintendent leighton
hammer
um as the sort of the command
um how they're broken down i don't know
i don't know how that's changed because
it's all very recent but i will
certainly find that out for you
um and i'll see if i can um ask
chief inspector bastard to come along
maybe if the chair would be interested
in that to give us a bit of an
update on how operation raptors working
across the county
yes i mean i i don't want to get i don't
i wouldn't want you to reveal any
operational issues
but i just really need to know how they
compare
um to the west and the south please
yeah i will find that information out
for you
just like that thank you very much thank
you chairman
yes sir anybody else tara
yes kevin i've still got a list
unfortunately um i've got
uh councillor fleming is next german
fleming please
thank you chair um a question for the
chief inspector
can i just ask how many are actually on
the rural team at the moment
i'm just looking back at my notes um i
think the last time we met you said that
the team would go up to eight and you
mentioned vacancies at the moment
so how many are actually on the team
today
so my rule engagement team as it stands
at the moment is six
of which one of those unfortunately is
isolating so has to work from home so
i've got
two vacancies to fill on that um
which in our last round
of um applications we
only found one person and that was
literally i got had that confirmed for
me yesterday um
whether where that person's going i'm
not sure if they're going on to
the main cpt or the rural part of it um
i need to check that with the inspector
running it
but we are now looking to do a force
wide advertisement to see if we can get
some more people if that doesn't work
um then i will be looking at doing
enforced
postings of officers into those
jobs which i think are crucial um
why do people not want to well why is it
not that
popular um some of it
is we've got a really young in-service
workforce
at the moment and they
don't see rural crime as exciting
gotta be honest with you they want to
drive around in fast cars and
you know do all of the stuff they see on
tv
and they don't feel they can get that
we're trying
to change that mindset um which is never
a quick thing to do
um also it's it's distance it's
location of where we're having to um
post people to
um there has been i'm going to be
perfectly honest with you
some concern about uh from the community
team
about postings to malden because of the
extra cost they will have for travel
etc but um i'm having to be quite
draconian
about the measures i'm putting in place
around that
to ensure that we um we put the right
people in the right place
good thank you
anybody else tara chairman castleman is
next
cast
[Music]
thank you very much chairman and um
right good evening chief inspector thank
you very much for your presentation
uh i'm really pleased um to know if i've
interpreted what you said correctly that
you're looking at beefing up
local policing and local deployment
because you know as a lay person but a
person on the street
so to speak i don't think you can beat
local policing
uh in many ways i wonder if things have
turned full circle
and i can't help but think that the
disposal
of the police station uh wasn't a good
idea
after all although i was reassured
at the time by the police and crime
commissioner
um that the building was no longer fit
for purposes
but at least there was space and at
least it was central
um do you have any thoughts about that
at all
right um the the selling of police
estate is a political issue and i'm not
going to get into that one
um so um
for me um my background was i was your
community policing
inspector before i got promoted i want
my community bobbies in the community
that's the only way it works as far as
i'm concerned so
i want to be putting my community team
out where they're policing and
i need space to do that yes
um very diplomatic answer thank you
chief inspector
um uh but yes i i agree with
agree with you in terms of bobby's on
the beat you know
i look back at the time when uh um
mr pipe was up and down the high street
on his bike and richie miller was up and
down the high street
and there's no substitute for that
really but uh
thank you very much for what you are
doing but when i uh
see the police and crime commissioner
although he's quite elusive
really um i will be
asked in that question about the police
station
thank you next one tara
thank you chairman uh councilman morris
next chairman that's the morris
welcome good evening
um how are we doing chair are you okay i
think sir
how are you great great yeah i just need
to uh
comment that uh you've got a lovely warm
glow about you this evening
then i notice you've got a light source
behind you so that's the reason
thank you for letting me speak um good
evening chief inspector
uh scott hayes good evening i'm good
yourself
yeah get in there mate get in there
thank you very much just um i'd like to
go to the report and uh
3.1.3
close to the bottom approximately four
or five lines in
um it's reports of kovid19
breaches around social distancing as far
as i'm aware
is social distancing covered by
legislation
as i believe it to be a guideline is
that correct sir
so my understanding and
this changes so often so i'm sure you're
aware
um my understanding is that social
distancing
is a guideline yeah um
other parts of the um
covid guidelines legislation
um do have powers attached um
i would say that one doesn't have a
specific power attached is my
understanding
after reading the uh the full
legislation quite soon after it came out
i'm unaware of any actual legislation
that's around social distancing
and sadly some of your officers are
actually stating to the public
that um various parts of guidance is
actually law
when it isn't so uh you know i'd
encourage uh
all your officers to uh get get a better
grasp of it really
because you know trying to enforce
guidelines as law
and then threatening people with the
rest of them it's uh is a little bit
naughty should we say
thank you inspector no problem counselor
thank you
anybody chairman next i've got cancer
flickr if he stood on the
on the line he was having problems with
his internet okay
luka he is still here
uh hello of order chair what's the
problem
uh why is councillor fluker asking a
question
he asked to speak and it's the
chairman's prerogative let people speak
if they want to
like other people aren't on this
committee
as a member of the public
i don't know what he is he hasn't said
at the moment
he's asked to speak he is suspended from
all committees
can i refer you to the council's
decision please
yes you may but ma referred to the fact
that he can
attend a meeting if he asked the
chairman but not to take part in the
meeting
to make decisions just to ask questions
like any other counselor can appear at
any other meeting
and do the same thing could i have my
point minutes please could i have my
point minuted please yes you might
if you want to tell me an opinion
can i offer an opinion please chairman
go on councillor morris thank you chair
just to say that even though i'm fully
respectful
of councillor nylon councillor bell
bringing to the committee's
attention i do believe that every
councillor
should be allowed to speak can i have
that many
please thank you councillor morris for
that thank you for supporting me
uh it's not a problem i'm not supporting
you i'm supporting free speech
and even even though the history
of this is quite evident can we just
please move on please
is council spoke here or not germany is
on the call but it looks like he
might be having problems um speaking so
should i move to the next person yes
move to the next person please
so the next person's counselor whole
chairman thank you that's the whole
please
oh thank you very much for letting me
speak and i'd just like to say
um without rural team fried denji
um we have quite a good link that's
gender crop dryers
um they we have a whatsapp group but um
it's quite worrying to
realize that a lot of people aren't um
reporting crimes because they're saying
they they're getting um
threatened if they report the crimes
which is quite worrying um also just to
say
uh where we are at elm farm i've got a
venue for the rural team if
they want to come in to have a coffee or
and
the community team are welcome to do the
same because they used to say
they'd have to come from burnham or
wherever down here at the denji
to champion to get a vehicle to come
back so if ever you want to use this
to park a car or whatever you want to do
you're welcome
just say that please thank you for that
counselor can i just say
if we if we have people who are
concerned about um
reporting crime because they feel
they're going to be threatened
um that's another crime it's really
straightforward that's another crime
if crimes aren't reported to me i can't
argue the case that i need to put more
people in the location
so i'd really encourage people to report
it
if people want to report it online they
can
by telephone or go to crime stoppers
if they're really worried crime stoppers
it's completely anonymous
and i am crime stoppers get that
information to us
to show how anonymous crime stoppers is
in my previous role
as an intelligence manager i would get
information around
murders and crime stoppers would not
give me the detail of that person
it's that anonymous so please encourage
people to
report it if it's reported i've i've got
more
ammunition then to stand before my chief
and say
i need more officers boss so that that's
yeah it's a really key point is that we
feel quite vulnerable because they can
seem set like
the fight you know the barns and things
and
yeah so i'll put that to them thank you
thank you councillor
thank you tara as anybody else
uh chairman the last person i've got is
councillor fleming is asking to come
back i believe
right okay council thank you chair a
question for the
chief inspector can i just ask about um
do you have any stats for covid uh
related fines for this area
right i haven't for our local area what
i can tell you is that certainly last
weekend we issued our first
50 000 pounds fine
which was for a wedding reception in
margareting
where the the manager of the venue
ignored all of the information they were
given knew fully what they were doing
and we rightly
issued them with a fixed penalty notice
on that
certainly over that same weekend we had
a number of issues in but
actually was in colchester where over 30
fines were issued
um we're issuing very few in malden and
chelmsford
the vast majority of people are doing
exactly the right thing
when we we will always try
to engage and encourage first and
i've been really clear with the officers
to do that
but where we need to enforce we will
enforce um
operation tala which is our response to
kovid
have just upped our patrols etc
and they are now taking all of that
information
around how many fixed penalty notices
we're giving how many times we're
interacting with people
etc so for the next meeting i will have
that data but right now we don't have it
um can i just ask how
how are you sort of engaging with with
young people
at this time you're taking a softly
softly approach
because i'm conscious it is quite a
difficult situation for them
yeah um
how do i put this right so we've used
the four e's approach
from the very beginning of lockdown and
invariably that has worked
um the tolerance of
the public over people not doing what
they're supposed to do
has changed and we have seen that change
so i would say with young people and
older people we we have continued
with our engagement talking to people
asking them to move apart move on
um 99 do that
you know the one percent that don't we
are now
issuing fines that we probably weren't
doing at the beginning of this
okay right thank you
tara's anybody else
yes chairman sorry counselor siddal's
asked to come back house is settled by
all means come back
thank you chairman thank you chief
inspector um
from a personal point of view and
looking at the figures
and something that i've sort of
experienced over the last year or so
is the increase in hate crime on your
statistics is quite shocking
is that something in particular that
that is occurring is it is it
to do with pressure on people yeah so
i'm quite concerned as a gay man
that hate crime has has gone up by so
much in the in the modern area
yeah we we've seen a number of um
repeat victims is the honest answer to
this
um so this was actually highlighted
um about six weeks six eight weeks ago
um when we saw the figures starting to
increase we've had
um lou middleton who's our hate crime
officer
for the north um doing a lot more work
in the area
and looking at if there is a particular
person
a particular place we call it the
triangle of um
crime you know victim
[Music]
location and suspect
and looking at all three of those and
putting a more holistic view around
do we need to educate do we need to
enforce
do we need to go into
a specific location and put something
around that location
so we're doing the work around those
what we haven't found although we found
a number of repeat
victims we haven't found a repeat
suspect if that makes sense
yeah we're not seeing a specific
increase in individuals or groups
going after other individuals and groups
but some people seem to be more prone to
being victimized
than we thought was the case originally
so we're doing a lot of work on it
but it's one of those really difficult
ones where
what exactly is the spark that's doing
it as we're not sure
we haven't seen the same increase in
chelmsford
which does concern me we've seen a
little a smaller spike
but certainly in modern we have seen
more and that's again
more of a reason why i want the bobbies
out there
people won't do this kind of thing in
front of a bobby it's really
straightforward
because they know they'll get caught and
what i want to ensure is that our
visibility is such that we are
protecting the most vulnerable in our
communities
because it is a very difficult crime to
report and and
yeah and and the fact that yeah
when someone wants to report it they
feel nervous about doing that
um and about the situation that they're
under but i think it is important that
you know that we yeah and having hate
crime weak is very very important and
it's good that the council is promoting
it
um so that we do ensure that those sort
of issues are taken
are brought to the police i mean we
we have to be honest and say that but
the police um
certainly 20 years ago when i started
we're not great at dealing with this
kind of thing
we have come on in leaps and bounds um
and we've really listened to partners
to understand how we should deal with
these things i think we're progressing
i think we still got a ways to go but um
we need it reported the more it gets
reported the better we
that we can deal with it and i think
certainly for the malden
um district as a whole um i think it'd
be a really good idea for us to have an
independent advisory group
separate to the one held at chelmsford
you have different problems here you
have a different community a different
demographic and i'd really like to get
that
up and running so that we can bring
these hate crimes to a specific forum
with partners there and with local
representatives there so that we make
sure we do the right thing
is that something the council would
facilitate with you
right so it's this is a really difficult
one because they're independent they're
the independent advisory group
it's quite difficult for the police to
start it so
what we need is someone i don't know we
may have a counsellor who has an
interest in this sort of thing
who would be willing to look to be a
chair and start
building on that and i could put that
person in
touch with them so i i want you to do
that now
excellent i will put you in contact with
exactly the right person counsellor
okay thank you very much yeah because it
is it is really important that
the these things are reported yeah
right thank you you've got you can get
my details and everything
i'm very happy to champion that and take
that forward
thank you okay tara is anybody else
no chairman that's it right thank you
thank you very much chief inspector for
your report very interesting
very detailed and i think members found
that very interesting
thank you very much thank you very much
thank you very much thank you yes
thank you very much thank you very much
move on to item seven molden district
community safety partnership update
uh in a moment i will call on officers
to present this item members
reminder that if you wish to speak on
this item please make the
make known using the chat function
within the meeting i will then
come to you in turn please keep your
points clear and concise
mr holmes would you like to uh
start off please thank you chairman i'll
be handing straight over to spencer
clark the
public protection manager at chelmsford
uh city council who obviously provides
our management service of our community
safety activities
and i think he's broadcasting from his
cctv control room so i'll hand to
spencer now
thank you very much carry on
thank you chair thank you okay um
so i've got a agenda item seven which is
the
report which i usually um bring to
members
i will just go through the salient
points of the report because hopefully
members of that had an opportunity to
read it in advance
um and uh as uh mr holmes said i'm uh
i'm live from the cctv control room so
uh
i will be showing members of the modern
cameras
at some stage this evening just to give
you some reassurance
of the quality of them so uh firstly on
page 13 which is the start of the report
looking at the statutory duties um there
wasn't
a meeting in march uh due to covid so
the last meeting we had was uh
october last year so i'll just
re-reiterate what the
five priorities for the partnership are
for this coming year
and uh there's also already been a
decision
these priorities are going to stay the
same for next year as well
so uh when we do the strategic
assessment which we do each year it will
be
a light touch one this year because uh
because of the
um implications of covid some of the
actual work
we've wanted to do we've haven't haven't
been able to crack on with it as much as
we'd like to have done
so uh those five priorities you'll
you'll see him there um
tackling crime and uh reducing offending
driving down anti-social behavior in
public places
identifying and supporting vulnerable
people
increase confidence in identifying
reducing rural crime
and finally one around road safety and
challenging
irresponsible driving so i'm sure you
all agree they're all
all clear goals for what we have in mold
at the moment
so going on to page 14
i have flagged up about some of the um
work we've done
with bdo around the internal audit which
i'll come on to later in the report
but you'll see that um members have had
a copy of their
action plan which has been amended and
it's proposed that every overview and
scrutiny meeting we have in future
you'll have a copy of the action plan
updated
with all the clear tasks in there a red
amber green rating
and the proposed financial spend on each
one of those projects so i won't say too
much about police performance because uh
chief inspector
scott haynes has already reported on
police police
performance um just really to reiterate
the issues which not just uh
molden's been experiencing but across
the whole of essex
so uh service requests for things like
antisocial behavior
um have uh have increased significantly
but i will put a marker on that because
uh
throughout the covid crisis and
throughout lockdown the police analyst
was
looking at these figures for us in great
detail and uh
for the chancellor of malden district
we're getting at least
usually about 100 reports a month purely
down from people not being happy with
their neighbors about social distancing
so whether we agree that's true true
anti-social behaviour is such as
just a word of warning on that the sort
of stuff we saw
out on the streets was uh certainly
places like prom park
we had a lot of youngsters out and i'm
sure you can all relate to this a lot of
youngsters out
drinking alcohol and using nitrous oxide
canisters
so um that was quite prevalent during
the summer months
i i also vice chair safer essex so
that's the same story across the whole
of essex
that seems eased up a bit now with
schools going back and college is going
back
one of the other areas which the chief
inspector also flagged up is around
domestic violence
um because people were locked down in in
a locality um there was a concern that
there would be a
large peak in domestic violence the
police haven't actually seen that agency
haven't seen that there has been though
a number of
increases for support though through the
essex compass
on 3.14 um just speaking a little bit
about
preventing violent extremism we have an
action plan in place for that and uh
i review the quarterly counter-terrorism
local profile
which comes in um and we also spoke
about um the independent advisory group
so uh that actual independent advisory
group
was set up for chelmsford and molden we
used to have quite a few mild members
come along to that
so uh perhaps uh i can have a discussion
with councillor city outside that
meeting because we've been
meeting on zoom recently so uh perhaps
we can
have a discussion around how we can take
that forward i'd be really pleased to be
could take that forward
on 3.15 um just flagging up about
modern-day slavery and human trafficking
um this morning i spent two and a half
hours
on a uh um watching the ra ra theater
company
deliver a play on uh human trafficking
entitled my mind is free so we done a
session on the 14th
of october for malden and in another
session today for chelmsford
it's a fantastic performance it was and
then it broke into
workout groups where a number of
different agencies were able to speak
to professionals about modern day
slavery and human trafficking
and you'll see that there's a a link at
the end of that paragraph
for the lga on work around modern day
slavery
on 3.2 which is at the top of page 15
uh there's an update around uh the
police farm and crime commissioner
activities
um what i didn't put in my report
because i don't think it was a
set in the stone at the time is uh the
police fire and crime commissioner
public meeting
for malden will be held on monday the
2nd of november
so i'll make sure that gets out to all
members i think that's a 6 pm start
we did a similar session um about a
month ago for chelmsford
and there's quite a large audience for
that so it really
i thought it worked quite well so uh
that that that
that date is monday the 2nd of november
again
um you'll see all the 3.22 is about the
funding
and where um the commissioner has put a
lot of money towards
charities this year
and also uh further down in the report
it's states about the police in numbers
and uh
the increase in the town center teams
and the rural
engagement team further down on that
report it goes into the
about the essex violence and
vulnerability unit
um that's based in the community safety
hub
they actually sit about 2 me well two
and a half meters away from my desk
so they are socially distanced when
they're there um so uh they uh
um do an incredible amount of work
around vulnerability
and tackling exploitation of young
people
on to the next page which is a page 16
just an update about some of the works
which we're doing
like uh most other agencies uh we've had
to go
on to virtual platforms um so
um monthly tasking which was uh done on
tuesday is now done on microsoft teams
we're still getting very good attendance
for that
and you'll see that referring again to
our action plan which goes through the
detail of all of the work which we're
doing
we get regular people turning up uh you
can see i won't go for all those groups
but
lots of different groups are turning up
to tasking which
makes it uh a true exercise on how we
can actually help the police and other
agencies tackle crime
finally uh on to the next part on this
page
just updating around the mace meetings
so i attend the mid mace meetings which
is
missing in child exploitation so they're
held on microsoft teams as well
and also attend middlesex stay safe i'm
the vice chair of bitter six children's
partnership board
and also attend like the chief inspector
the mold champion mold and behaviour and
attendance partnerships
so there's quite a lot of meetings which
officers
and agencies attend to tackle and reduce
crime
um i won't go into the areas about
policing around up enlightenment because
the chief inspectors already
spoke about that um but i will sort of
uh talk about some of the other works
we're doing around mental health
we continue to have the um mental health
groups for mid
um and uh we've also managed to get
neighborhood watch
onto the virtual platform which is good
so we've been
holding mold and neighborhood watch
meetings on microsoft
teams which has enabled us to keep the
dialogue on going
um on 3.3 um
you'll see that we've been busy
delivering safeguarding and enhanced
safeguarding on virtual platforms for
staff
which has included producing a suicide
awareness flow chart
and uh worthy of note that we've knew
we've also got a new police officer in
the team pc chris major who is uh
one of the new community and safety
engagement officers for essex police
um we'll be getting another officer in
january
so it'll be one for champion and one for
malden and that will be
all about improving engagement with our
communities
so you'll see things like facebook live
sessions which they'll be doing
so that's a real real positive
area just a few of the actual events
we've been doing so uh
um we helped out with essex fire and
rescue service
um on the second and third of september
and burnham on crouch
a safe well and secure event um
i attended one of those days and claire
uh our office officer
attended the next day fairly enjoyable
event we
knocked on over 800 doors during those
two days
and had about 30 really positive
referrals
um two of the doors whilst initially it
was mainly about home safety two of the
doors i knocked on
out the first three um one was an
elderly person who we referred to
for an additional handrail for a
property and the next
next next door there was a 88 year old
lady who was a
profoundly deaf who if she even she
would have had a smoke alarm wouldn't
have heard it
so we fitted a sensory smoke alarm to
her property so there's
i thought really positive events doing
ones like that
we also uh last monday um
supported a week of action around
tackling metal thefts and illegal waste
carriers
this event was done by the community
safety team the community engagement
team
essex police rule engagement team and
hmrc as well
we also had the high sheriff turn up to
this event um
stopped over 100 cars that day
there were 10 out 10 10 referrals alone
for work which the district council have
to do i'm not sure how many policing
ones there were
but it's really good event for the day
and also uh
just flagging up last week was a
national hate crime awareness week
so the district council provided daily
social media posts for that week
just to raise the awareness of hate
crime
um 3.34 and this is where i'm going to
be as tech as i can be
i thought about sharing a screen but i
thought i know i'm going to do this live
so you can actually you know it's more
believable now
so um i've been working on a capital
project
for chelmsford and molden to procure
a cctv system
this contract was awarded um on the
first of april
um so a large majority of these works
were done during lockdown
which was um meant we got on quite well
so uh all of the cameras we've put in at
molden
are now been migrated to a uh digital
high definition units and they've got
full
connectivity over a secure
video management system so the areas
which we're covering in molden and i'm
not going to show you them all tonight
because we'll be here all night
are uh the high street uh promenade park
hive key and there's also a couple of
extended areas which uh
which uh um riverside park in
burnham and a couple of our community
centers so they're monitored here where
i am now
in the champs cctv control room
um it's malden's been effectively live
since the 1st of july
and uh what i'm going to do quickly now
is i'm going to stand up and i know this
might look a little bit messy
but i'm going to show you
the cameras live on a large monitor
behind me there you go it's almost
seamless that wasn't it
so uh what i've done is i've got the
mould and cameras on a sequence
so as you see uh behind you we've got
the weather spoons of rose and crown
uh next to us um then we've got the sark
turkish restaurant on the other part of
the high street
so this is really just to sort of
reassure you bat lane car park
that we've got pretty good coverage of
malden molden
these uh cameras are monitored
24 7 365 days a year
and we've always got two members of
staff in this control room
and uh they're actually uh whilst i'm
showing you on the large monsters behind
me they're actually
also done on a very large
screen bank of monitors that you'll see
behind me there now um
there you go so uh that's that's the
actual control
that's the actual control room so you'll
see that uh we've got
uh we have two workstations there so uh
molding is on the main
monitor wall but also on this small one
behind so on
friday and saturday nights we have an
extra member of staff in there so that's
really just a very quick um
introduction to cctv for malden
perhaps when uh the lockdown
restrictions is we could have a group of
members come along
to actually uh have a look at the system
in detail
i'll drop back to my suit now if that's
okay
so that that's uh that's the cctv system
which has a
been put in to molden um and
uh not only has it been used for a
number of instances around
crime today but also um
it's been really useful uh around
covid as well so uh so things like
um ensuring that there's a adequate
uh spacing for the high street and how
we've been doing the design and it's
been
it's enabled the council to make more
informed decisions about what's actually
happening
so uh only last week we provided
footfall figures for
tuesdays and saturdays in line with the
government reporting
so the staff in the control room have
been doing those footfall counts
as as well so it's not just all about
crime it's also about
how we can also use it more effectively
so uh we spoke about hot spots for crime
um i think the chief inspector brought
these up a bit earlier
so uh really the hot spots for moulding
are are the high street because we've
got
uh drinking establishments in there
promenade
park where we tend to get some youth
nuisance over the summer months
and hive key where we've had some issues
uh
which uh both the police and the council
have been dealing with
um so uh what we have been looking at
is uh reviewing the possibility of
having a public space protection order
for the high street and those areas of
the park
so we could then use it to tackle things
like
inappropriate alcohol use outside those
public
conven public houses and drug misuse
um it's chief inspectors already spoken
about the work
which has been done around tackling
drugs
uh we've been continuing those works
another area which we got flagged up
quite a few times
over the summer months was uh
people coming out of lockdown and using
our inland waterways inappropriately
so places like home hill lock and be lee
falls uh
there's quite a few issues around
anti-spacial behavior
littering drunkenness and dangerous
parking so been working with the south
essex park in partnership
to tackle some of those issues and we've
also done some multi-agency
days with places like the fire people
like the fire service
and the environment agency to tackle
that
um finally a final point i was gonna
flag up because this is something which
um i need to refer to over in scrutiny
we had a bdo
audit internal audit of community safety
back in
back in april and uh the final report
was considered by
molden's performance
government and audit committee on the
30th of july
um the audit did have received moderate
assurance which is a is is
quite good in the in the ears of in ears
of uh
um uh auditors um and um
that was for design and operational
effectiveness but there was a few issues
which are flagged up
one of those was about the responsible
authorities group not meeting as
regularly as
what it should do so that's been
rectified now by
uh putting meetings into the diary for
the next
up until march 21 and uh the other one
was about how
we report back um to rag
and overview and scrutiny on performance
so that's why
what they asked for was an action plan
with everything specific put into the
action plan which was attached as an
appendix
with a red amber green rating to show
you what
where we are on performance for each of
those and also that
the responsible authorities group also
gets a quarterly report on finance
and you'll see that spend on finance has
also been
put into that action plan as well so uh
the responsible authorities group when
we met
last on the 8th of september was happy
that all of those recommendations have
been
completed and therefore the purpose of
this discussion here is i
am now reporting back to over in
scrutiny
to say that the responsible authorities
group is happier that those have been
completed
so um you'll see i put the conclusion in
there about the joint working
which we're doing and uh back
to page one for the actual uh
recommendations that you note the report
and note that the actual actions for the
bdo report have been completed as well
chair
thank you all right i'll do the next bit
uh thank you the recommendation to send
out the report
is as follows that members review and
comment on the current
progress of the initiatives undertaken
by the partnership to date and note the
strategic priorities
for 2020-21 and note the completion
completed recommendations of the
internal audit
of the community safety partnership if
any member wishes to second that motion
please turn on your video unmute your
microphone and state your name now
please
anybody
i i will second it thank you very much
sorry chairman i wasn't quite quick
enough with my um
mouse oh it's confusing which button to
press that's why i leave mine on all the
time if i have to keep pressing i'm lost
right if any members wish uh thank you i
will now invite members to make any
comments on the report
tara who's indicated to speak please
chairman a councillor bell
and then councillor morris councillor
bell please
thank you well thank you very much
spencer for that that was very
informative um i just wanted to
say that uh i believe there have been
some conversations
around cctv for burnham
and um with wendy stamp and just to say
that i'm very
keen to progress that that's that's
still very much on the table so
hope to be able to speak to you about
that in the future
would you like me to come back on that
uh chair yes please
yeah yes so i've i've spent uh uh some
time down in burnham with councillor
stamp
um we've done a survey of burnham and uh
put in some uh budgetary prices so we've
done a design for burnham and and
i agree with councillor bell that would
be really good if we could get that
extended to that area
excellent thank you through the chair
thank you
councillor morris i believe tara
yes chairman that's right and then
councillor fleming also is asked to
speak
that's the morris please thank you very
much
chair uh good evening spencer how are
you good evening
councillor morris i know if you've got
an extra big smile when you see me pop
up there
um spencer as you might remember that
for quite a few years now even before my
time as a counsellor
uh way back in the stephen cavanaugh
days i was always quite um
interested in the vulnerability angle uh
because i didn't believe that
uh united states police were uh putting
enough into it
um so spencer i'd like to ask um
your third priority is vulnerability and
helping out vulnerable
people what is your definition of a
vulnerable person
could you give me the legal definition
of a vulnerable person
i can't give you the legal definition of
a vulnerable person so
um what i would say you know why you
can't give me a
do you know why you can't give me the
definition of a vulnerable person
legally because there isn't one would
that be the case there isn't one
okay it took me it took me a month
absolutely months and i've been working
on this for quite a few years
to actually get anything from essex
police and i finally got
a freedom of information uh request and
it comes from
peel police effectiveness 2015
vulnerability and i would just like to
read this out
the definition of a vulnerable victim
would be an individual eligible for
extra support under the code of practice
for victims
defined in the code as an individual who
was
under the age of 18 at the time of the
offence
or whose quality of evidence is likely
to be affected because of a mental
disorder
another significant impairment of
intelligence and social functioning
or who has a physical disability
or is suffering from a physical disorder
uh
the um next to that is that is
the definition of vulnerability which
would be condition of a person
who is in need of special care support
or protection
because of age disability or risk of
abuse
or neglect now as we all know
quite a lot of the people you come into
contact with would fit that criteria
but your officers and i know some of
them are very good
some of them are not so good as with all
different professions
and and whatever else but how are you
going to get the message across
to your bobbies on the beat what a
vulnerable person
is
would you like to answer that
well i can't i can't do answer uh on
behalf of the police because i don't
work for the police
i don't know if mr scott haynes is still
in the call but uh
when i when i when we talk about
vulnerability you can see
that in the brackets with for domestic
abuse
social isolation mental health
hate crime could be young people being
exploited it could be old people being
exploited
so it is a very i agree with your
council it's a very very wide
area we're looking at and we can only
work with those people we know and
that's one of the really big
difficulties around
social isolation you know people who may
live out
on their on the denji peninsula trying
to get
them to access services trying to get
them to know that the exact
services to be accessed is really really
difficult you know
so you know i i agree with you but i
can't
i can't answer that question on behalf
of the police though about what is a
vulnerable person
um thank you very much spencer um you've
had
as well probably five years warning that
this might be coming
i don't i thought i believe that you
never expected to see me sitting here
as a elected counselor asking you that
question so uh i'll let that one go
um but as with most problems i do
believe the answer would lie
with education and and better training
um thank you spencer and thank you chair
thank you very much councillor morris
very
informative uh we've got councillor
fleming now i believe
thank you chair thank you spencer for
that uh
thanks for showing us the control room
i'm much reassured because i often walk
my dog
down the high street in the evening when
it's dark so now i know that you'll be
you and your staff will be there
watching over me um
but my question was about the
3pr project um i see that it's on hold
due to covid
do you have um any news when that would
be
restarted
yeah i think i think there's actually
been been restarted now
so um so we i know the officer who
works for the safe physics parking
partnership
has still been making contacts with
schools um
i think one of the problems we've had
with schools is uh
um some some some some schools do not
want anyone going into at the moment and
i
totally see that and it's it it just
means that we've had to
like like we're doing tonight we have to
do things differently
you know like i said earlier in my
report um last year
when my officers went to clacton to see
the raf
ralph theater company do a performance
it wasn't
overzoom on youtube like it was today so
we just have to think about different
ways of doing it so i think
that young lady has been looking after
that has been doing some of the
education online
but trying to get because so many
schools particularly primary schools
have had so much to do around
covid and social distancing them one way
in one way out i think
parking has just gone on the back burner
to a certain extent
which which is a shame but you know
we'll you know
we won't be like this forever but we'll
continue
hopefully we'll continue having that
dialogue with the schools
and seeing what we can do to reduce you
know the impact of the
irresponsible parking around schools
great
good spencer and it was um yeah
heartwarming to know that your visits
with claire
you know just just reaching those two
elderly residents you know with with
something
practical um you know really makes a
difference because they don't they don't
ask for help um you know that age group
so yeah good good work thank you
thank you anybody else tara
oh no chairman no one else has indicated
they wish to speak
right um i'll ask the committee
to agree the recommendation by
sent if possible you agreed
agreed agreed you very much for doing
your report
very good very informative even though
you're to ask trying to ask some awkward
questions but never mind
that's how it goes isn't it right any
other urgent business
that the chairman decides are urgent i'd
like to thank everyone for putting up
with me and wish my successor every luck
in the future
uh and i'll now close the meeting at
1929. thank you all
thanks michael future
you